WESLEY CHUN: Hi.
This is Wesley Chun.
You know how uploading and
downloading files is pretty
easy for Google Drive users?
Well, today, we're
going to show you
that it's just as easy for
developers using the Drive API.
As a bonus, we'll also introduce
the latest and greatest version
of the API, so
let's start there.
The Drive API was launched along
with Google Drive back in 2012.
Since then, the team has
been innovating and improving
the API along with
listening to user feedback.
In the newest version, v3, we
changed to more sensible method
and field names, removed
duplicate functionality,
and reduced the amount of
data returned from API calls.
As a result, v3 is
leaner and faster.
I caught up with Steve Bazyl,
who's the developer platform
engineer for Google Drive, to
help me introduce developers
to v3.
So I gave a quick intro to
the new version of the API
at the top of the
show, but maybe you
could tell us what was the
team specifically trying
to accomplish with this release?
STEVE BAZYL: Sure.
So when we launched the
API a couple years ago,
we did what we
thought was right.
But after a few
years of seeing how
the API was used in production
and talking to developers
about what they were
trying to accomplish,
we found that there's a
really good opportunity
to simplify the API and focus
on speed and performance.
WESLEY CHUN: So in addition
to the space and time
savings, were some things
made easier for developers?
STEVE BAZYL: Definitely, yes.
I think one of the
biggest improvements
was around downloading files.
In the older version of the
API, downloading and exporting
Google Docs and Sheets was
a little bit complicated,
and having to deal
with export links.
So we created a new
API method explicitly
for exporting documentation,
and downloads in general
are a lot simpler in the API.
WESLEY CHUN: So
one of the things
that developers are concerned
with when a new API comes out
is that the old one
or the current one
is immediately obsolete.
Is that the case with this one?
STEVE BAZYL: Not this time.
Normally that would be the
case when we release a new API,
but for now, we're going to
keep both versions of the API
running.
V3 doesn't really
add any new features.
It's primarily focused
on simplifying the API,
making it faster out of
the box, and it's really
targeted for new developers
getting started with the API.
So for those who have existing
projects, no need to panic.
V2 is going to continue
to work for really
the next couple years.
WESLEY CHUN: OK.
Well, cool.
So let's say I do
have an existing
app using the current
version, which is v2.
Is it possible for me
to start a new component
to that app using v3?
Can they kind of
live side by side?
STEVE BAZYL: Of course, and
that's a really great way
to get started with v3.
Just pick something that
is new, maybe some code
that you want to refactor.
That's a great opportunity
to dip your toes into v3,
understand what changed,
how it would benefit you.
And if that goes
well, those people
might find out that the
rest of their application
would benefit from moving to v3.
But there's no rush to do it.
People feel like
they have the time
and they think they
would benefit, go for it.
There's a lot of gains
that they'll get.
But again, no need to panic.
Really just take it easy.
WESLEY CHUN: OK.
Cool.
So there's a lot of developers
out there using Google Drive,
but they may all be using
different development
environments.
What languages are
supported by the Drive API?
STEVE BAZYL: So we
have client libraries
for most of the common
languages out there.
So if you're java.net, you do
Objective-C or Swift for iOS,
PHP, Python--
WESLEY CHUN: Python.
Oh, that's my favorite.
STEVE BAZYL: Python 2.
There's client libraries for
most languages, Node.js, even
a client-side
JavaScript library,
and they all work with the API.
Some of them are easier
to use than others,
but really, all
of them are going
to get you a lot
closer to having
your code ready than if you
just wrote your own client.
And of course,
these are REST APIs.
So if you are more
comfortable dealing
with just whatever
HttpClient you
have or some other
REST library that you
happen to be using, go
ahead and use those.
It's going to work
just the same.
You might have to do a little
bit more work, particularly
for uploads and
downloads and some
of the more complicated parts,
but the vast majority of it
is pretty easy to use
pretty much on any platform.
WESLEY CHUN: OK, great.
So that's good news that a
lot of developers out there
could use the Drive API.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly, yeah.
WESLEY CHUN: All right.
Well, Steve, that was
really useful information.
I think developers have
all they need to know.
All we need to do is get
them started with it.
Thanks for stopping by today.
STEVE BAZYL: OK.
Thanks for having me.
WESLEY CHUN: Now let's
help you start using v3.
We're going to walk through
a simple code snippet
that uploads and downloads
files with the API,
including converting
to Google Apps format
and exporting as PDF.
We'll do this first using
the current version, v2, then
show you how we
improved things for v3.
So put on your coding hat, and
let's go to the computer now.
As in previous
episodes, we're going
to do it in Python
for brevity, and it
makes for great
pseudocode if you're
using something else
as your dev tool.
To see all the Google
API's client library
supported languages,
click the link onscreen
or down in the video description
below if you're on mobile.
Now, the first 20
or so lines are
nearly identical to
the auth boilerplate
we covered in depth at the
beginning of the video series.
Check out those videos,
especially the one
on the common code
walkthrough if you
missed these to understand what
it does and why it's needed.
There are some differences
in this modernized version.
The one you should
note are there's
an import of the print
function on line 1.
That will allow your script
to run in Python 2 or 3.
Then there's this import
block for the argparse module
in lines 20 and 21 so that your
script uses the new run flow
function from
oauth2client.tools, which
succeeds the run function
but falls back to the latter
if argparse is not available,
meaning you're using an older
version of Python.
Visit the link to the
blog post to find out
more info about this change.
Since we're using the Drive
API, we need the correct scope,
and that's on line 14.
Use the most restrictive
scope you can.
Here it's drive.file
because we're
creating files on Google Drive.
The more restrictive your
scope, the fewer permissions
you need to ask of your
users, and the safer
your code will be.
Now the first step.
Create a service
endpoint to Google Drive,
as you can see on line 22.
As mentioned earlier, we're
going to do this in v2 first,
then show you how the
code changes for v3.
Lines 24 to 27 are
the files to upload.
You can see that
they're two tuples,
with file names and a flag
for converting to Google Apps
format, a yes or a
no, and you can also
see that we're uploading
the same file twice--
first as is in plain text, then
convert to Google Apps format.
For the plain text
conversion, it's Google Docs.
But you can imagine
that for CSV files,
it'll be Google Sheets, right?
Now to the main
part of the script.
We're going to start with
the section to do uploads.
The for loop calls the
files.insert command
for each upload with parameters.
The first is the
convert flag, the body
is the file metadata, which
is just the file name.
The media body is
also the file name,
but it's slightly different.
This is where the data
is going to come from,
meaning that this file
is going to be opened
and the content sent to the API.
Finally, you should pass in
the fields you want returned.
Why is this important?
If not specified, you
get back a payload
with more than 30 fields.
Why waste all that network
traffic when you only
need a couple of them?
I just want the
MIMETYPE to confirm
how the file was
stored in Drive,
and I also want
the export links.
More on that soon.
On lines 33 and 34, if
the call is successful,
we're going to
display the file was
uploaded to the user,
including the MIMETYPE.
The final section
of the script is
where we wrap up our poor man's
plain text PDF conversion.
That is, to export and
download the Google Docs
version of the file as PDF.
Note that we still
have the result
from the second upload, which is
the Google Docs converted file.
Back to the export links.
We requested that
field because it
has the download links that we
need, specifically the PDF one.
How do we use it?
Well, we need to issue an
authorized HTTP get request
because there's no API call
for this, at least not in v2.
After the call completes,
check if we got the data.
If so, save to disk and display.
Success.
OK.
Let's save it and run it.
If you didn't already
know, the first time
you run a command-line script
like this, a browser window
is going to pop open with
the OAuth2 prompt, where
you have to authorize this
script to be able to get access
to the files in
your Google Drive,
or your users' Google Drive.
When you opt in,
the credentials are
going to be downloaded and
stored in this storage.json
file, so you only
need to do it once
unless you delete this file.
Anyway, let's just pretend that
all that has happened already,
and so we're just going to run
the script as if we didn't have
to worry about authorization.
We should see output for the
plain text version-- there
it is-- and in the Google Docs
converted version, and finally,
the download into PDF.
Now let's check the
Drive UI, web or mobile--
since I'm on a
computer, obviously it's
the web version-- to
confirm that we've
got two versions of the
Hello file uploaded.
So here's the plain text one.
You can get a preview of it.
There it is.
And then you can also get
a preview of the Google Doc
converted one,
and there that is.
The last thing we need to do is
check that we have a PDF file,
and we can do that pretty
easily from the command line,
confirm that it actually is
a PDF file, and then open it.
And there we are--
helloworld.pdf.
Great.
Now let's do the same thing,
but use v3 of the API instead.
So first, change the
API version to v3.
Now, one key change.
There's not going to be
a convert flag anymore.
The problem is that a Boolean
variable only gives you
two choices-- Google Apps
conversion or not at all.
There's no option to specify
what format you want.
If MIMETYPEs was used
instead of Booleans,
there's more flexibility for
conversion, either uploads
or downloads.
So in the first case, let's
change the false to none, which
is Python's null object,
meaning no conversion.
And in the second case, we need
the MIMETYPE for Google Docs,
and that's easily found.
Now we need to change
this convert variable
to reflect this change of data.
Now, we mentioned that v3
has better and more sensible
naming.
Here, the title field changes
to name, more accurately
reflecting that a file's
name is not its title,
but hello, its name.
Another change with using
the MIMETYPE instead
of the convert flag is that
instead of being a parameter,
it's actually going to be
part of the file metadata,
so we need to add that
if doing conversion.
Another improved
name change in v3
is that instead of
insert, create is actually
a better name or verb.
So that's what we're
going to change this to.
We have to get rid
of the convert flag,
the body stays the same, the
media body stays the same.
Lastly, fields is no longer
required, as v3 is more nimble,
returning much
less data than v2.
Fortunately, the things
that are returned
are actually the ones we need.
Finally, if successful, display
the uploaded file message
to the user.
Now let's see how export and
downloads are simplified.
First, another v3 change.
No more download links.
In other words, we don't
need to look for export links
and make an HTTP call.
Instead, both steps have been
simplified to a single API
request to the
files.export method.
If successful, the call will
yield the data we need to save.
So write it to disk and output
to the user just as before,
and that's it.
Now let's save and
run the v3 version.
The output should be
exactly the same as v2.
There's the plain text, there's
the Google Doc conversion,
and a download to PDF.
Now double check in your drive
UI that you got another two
files, and there they are.
I'll let you confirm that
the PDF was downloaded again
successfully.
And that's it.
Now you know how to upload
files to Google Drive using
v2 and v3 with or without
conversion to Google Apps
format.
Awesome.
So as you can see, it's not
too bad if you're using v2.
But better yet, if you
use the newest version,
you can take advantage of all
the improvements that we made.
Either way, we hope
this sample inspires
you to write your own
app using the Drive API.
To get started,
click the link that
takes you right to our docs.
Want a deeper look at the
code covered in this video?
Well, jump to the blog
post at the second link.
And to see other DevBytes in
our developer video series,
check out the links
at the bottom.
Now that you know how to
upload and download files
with and without
conversion, we hope
this jumpstarts your next
project using the Google Drive
API.
If you like this video,
subscribe and check out
our other DevBytes.
I'm Wesley Chun from
Google, and we'll
see you the next time
on the Launchpad Online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]